سماء اوروبا الغربيه ومن خلفها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بدت اخيرا كانها تمطر
دبابات قتاليه متطوره على الطرق المؤديه
الى ارض اوروبا الشرقيه او
مشتهين
لاوكرانيا هذا القرار كان نتيجه مشاوره
مكثفه مع حلفائنا وشركائنا الدوليه
31 دبابات ابرامز الى اوكرانيا
لاوكرانيا في مواجهه الغزو الروسيه منذ ما
يقرب من سنه ثانيه بين ان الهدير
المتعاليه من عشرات وربما مئات الدبابات
التي قد يستغرق نقلها الى تخمر روسيا بضعه
الشهور وكذا ما اثارت من الغبار الكفيف في
اوساط الدبلوماسيه الدوليه قبل ان تحط
جنازرها على التراب الاوكرانيات
كفيين لايقاظ قرفان من حروب الامبراطوريه
وعالميه طالما ظن الاوروبيون بان قارتهم
تجاوزتها الى غير رجعه صحيح ان الزمن
يتغير عما كان عليه حين اتجهت الدبابات
الالمانيه لتغزو روسيا في مستهلي
اربعينيات القرن الماضي وصحيح ان
الجغرافيا تغيرت ايضا ومعاها تغيرت
التحالفات الدوليه لا سيما بعد انتهاء
الحرب البارده لكن ردود الفعل الاوليه
التي بدرت من موسكو اذا اما يمكن وصفه
بشتاء الدبابات الغربيه ابقت الباب مفتوحا
على احتمالات خطيره في ربيع السنه الثانيه
من الحرب هذه خطه محكوم عليها بالفشل
والدبابات ستحترق قال لك كريم لان بينما
قالت سفارته لدى برلين ان القرار
الالمانيه يرفع الصراع الى مستوى جديد وان
المانيا تتخلى بموجبها عن مسؤوليتها
التاريخيه
روسيا في اشاره اردت التذكره على ما يبدو
بالنتائج التي ادت اليها هزيمه النازيه
امام الجيش الاحمر في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وان من دون ان يفصح قائلها الروس
عن المقصود بذلك على وجه الدقه سؤال
الجدول المتوقعه من ارسال الدبابات
الغربيه الى اوكرانيا لم يعد هو الحال هذه
مجرد سؤال تقنيه يتعلق بتاثير المتغير
الجديد على الميزان العسكري لحربها مع
روسيا قدرا ما يعكس نجاح اداره الرئيس
الامريكي
في اعاده العواصم الاوروبيه الكبرى الى
حظيره التوافق شبه الكامل مع سياسه واشنطن
بعد شهور من التردد الالمانيه الناجمه عن
الحاجه الملحه لوالدات الطاقه الروسيه لا
بل بعد سنوات من التقارب المشهود الذي سبق
لموسكو ان حققته في علاقتها مع كل من
برلين وباريس ب عوامل اقتصاديه اهمها
مشروع خط الغاز العملاق نورد ستريم 2 الذي
توقف بعد ايام من الحرب كان انبوب الغاز
الشهير يوشكوا على التحول الى جسر بين
روسيا ودول غربي اوروبا حين تصاعد التوتر
في شرق اوكرانيا الى درجه استحتت الرئيس
بوتن ليدفع بجيشه نحو السياح لجاره اللدود
فيما سماها عمليه عسكريه هدفها استئصال من
وصفهم بالنازين هناك وهي عمليه تحولت شيئا
فشيئا الى ما يشبه حرب استنزاف او الى
فخريستراتيجي وفق بعض التقديرات ثم ها هي
توشك على دخول سنتها الثانيه وقد حل
الدبابات ليوبار الالمانيه محل انبوب
روسيه عنواننا لعلاقه روسيا مع بلدان
غربيه القاره في قرينه ترجح خساره القيصر
الروسي معركه الهيمنه والنفوذ امام
الامبراطوريه الامريكيه وقد تنظر بما لا
تحمد عقباها على الامن العالميه ان واصل
اعدائه المواجهه حتى هزيمته